ん
皆さんこんにちは長
突然ですか私から一つだけ質問をさせてください
皆さん
おならをスタートどういう反応しますか
例えば授業中我慢する人もいるかもしれません
ただ黙って知らないふりをする人もいるかもしれません
ジュンが
行ったのにも関わらず犯人性処する人もいるかもしれません
愉快に
オナラするぞ1 to slip みたいな子もいるかもしれません
しかし僕はどれもできずにいましたーーー
とにかく恥ずかしくて恥ずかしくて仕方ありませんでしょ
特に授業中なのかを並べたりしたら顔が赤くなって汗がだくだくになっちゃって隠す
こともできないし
我慢することはから体に悪いということは皆さんも知っていると思うからです
突然ですか私は大学になって彼女が出来ました
ございます
しかしながら彼女の前でもおならをすることは貯められました
ん
おならに気を使っていたんです
うんえっ
おならのせいで今日使う関係になっていたのかもしれません
えっ
しかし僕もそんな関係はやだなと思っていました
これは乗り越えなきゃいけないと本気で思いました
勇気を持って彼女に相談しましたん
どうしよう
ふたりでいるときどうしようと
30分ぐらい本気で話し合います
その時でたんが僕が紹介したりアイディアです
皆さんもおうちで言って着ると思うんです
面白いおならをしたして方がアイスをおごってもらえる
実際私も1個もうすでに奢ってもらっています
えっ
はいん
確かに私にとってはコナラは恥ずかしいことです
もちろんするのも恥ずかしかったことですしかし
おならをすれば笑わせることができるとか
オナラをすることによって号褒美がもらえるそういう風に捉えると積極的にできるん
ですね
不思議な音です
もちろんされた本を少し汚いなぁとは思うんですけどやっぱり笑っちゃうんですよ
みんな笑顔になれるんです
思います
恥ずかしいことをやりづらいことを
何かご褒美がもらえたりとか
払ってもらえたりとか
何か得られるものとか
楽しければ
積極的にできるのかもしれません
今回おならで1つの例を挙げましたが宿題とかそういうことに対してもそうかもしれ
ません
仕事とかそうかもしれません
おならはこう褒美がもらえるかな
ありがとうございましたます